Please discuss how we women and men can receive a safe and proper biopsy that will not leave cancer cells in our bodies
to later start seeding other tumors.
That brings us to the question of, do biopsies cause metastasis?
An autistic oncologist will say, yes, they can.
In fact, I just pulled up this article right here that does state, this is from an August 2017 article in this journal that does state that core needle biopsies of breast cancer is associated with a higher rate of distance metastasis 5 to 15 years after diagnosis.
So, what I mean, think of a biopsy, you know, you're going to go into the core needle biopsy to a breast cancer, they have to go in with the needle and then they're pulling that out and by when they pull it through the other tissue, some cells are being discharged.
So, you do risk the increased chance of metastasis with a biopsy.
The problem is, is that that doesn't mean that you shouldn't get a biopsy.
So, the truth is, is that the closer the tumor, if it's a breast tumor, the closer it is to the surface, your chance of, you know, causing a metastasis from the biopsy goes way down because you're actually pulling the needle through less tissue.
If it's a deeper tumor, you know, your chance, you know, will go up because you're pulling the needle through more tissue and you'll be letting more cells go outside of the tissue.
But the truth is, is that almost every cancer has given off circulating tumor cells long before the biopsy was even thought to be needed.
So, I'm not against doing biopsies, it's the only way we can get the pathology of the cell type anyhow.
So, you can't legally get a diagnosis of cancer without a biopsy.
So, biopsies are a necessary evil if, especially if you are going to do any care through your oncologist.
They're a necessary evil to find out the exact pathology that we're dealing with also.
However, we've had patients, you know, come to us that say, I feel like I have, you know, you know, breast cancer.
My doctor and breast cancer, my mom had breast cancer and this is growing.
They want to do a biopsy and I'm not going to do it. Could you just treat me as if I have that breast cancer?
Well, yes we can because we don't treat the cancer anyhow.
But in order to get a proper diagnosis, you need to get a biopsy.
That doesn't mean you need proper diagnosis to treat it from an alternative perspective.
But if you're going to do anything in the medical field, you're going to go and, you know, consider any of their care.
They're going to absolutely require, you know, a pathology report obtained through a biopsy.
So you're going to have to go through that necessary evil.
So, yeah, there isn't a safe and proper biopsy.
Let's take that back.
I think most biopsies are pretty safe.
You do increase the risk of attestances, but you increase the risk of attestances by having cancer.
So, it's, it's, it's pretty difficult to ascertain whether the attestances was because of the biopsy or was it just because that you have circulated tumor cells.
So, yeah, I just, it's a tough call.
It's not that any other way to truly diagnose cancer from seven biopsies.